I went to the movies all the time I was
I've seen the movies and at some point
it struck me rather dramatically how
much I wasn't in the movies not the way
I needed to be in the movies and if you
look at a lot of the disaster movies in
that period only people left on the
planet were white so now my thing is I
get into movies I wouldn't make sure
that I speak about that but if I'm able
to do it I want to talk about it so
there was a period there in the early
80s when I didn't get any work because I
would ask these questions I interviewed
for the movie the thing the remake so I
read the script and I go back for the
audition and the producer or the
director one was said did you read the
script I said yes what do you think I
said well you've got 11 people at the
South Pole eight of them scientists and
then you have a mechanic and something
else they're all black none of the
scientists are what do you think I think
needless just said and get that job
again though you know Providence rears
our beautiful head when glory came about
we asked ourselves we mean black people
why why aren't we why don't we figure
more in it I need something that's going
to engage me that makes me sit up and
think I refuse to take part in anything
that is going to denigrate a people
[Music]
especially me
I always tell my kids you lolly down
people will step over you but if you
keep scrambling if you keep calling
someone will always always give you a
hand always but you gotta keep dancing
you gotta keep your feet moving you just
watch - amazing clips of Morgan Freeman
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]